c'était dans la nuit de jeudi dernier
dans le quartier des hauts de saint
claude
lorsque la police arrive pour mettre un
terme à un rodéo urbain et à des tirs de
mortiers 2 individu sur un scooter fond
sur un agent de la bac et le blesse
grièvement à la jambe
si le phénomène des rodéo mécanique
n'est pas nouveau la violence physique
et psychologique qu'ils génèrent parfois
devient inquiétant aujourd'hui met en
oeuvre des mesures avant l'événement
après l'événement parce que intervenir
et la preuve en est encore la semaine
dernière intervenir sur le fait et
tenter de procéder à des interpellations
d'individus qui sont juchés sur des deux
roues et que refuse d'obtempérer aux
injonctions d'arrêt des policiers cela
est beaucoup trop dangereux du côté de
la mairie de besançon est bien sûr
conscient de l'exaspération des
habitants
même si le problème des rodéo mécanique
concerne toutes les villes le travail de
sensibilisation c'est sûr il faut le
faire ça résoudra pas dans l'immédiat et
mais il faut le faire il faut faire
confiance dans l'éducation
ça c'est une certitude maintenant pour
la répression c'est un travail qu'on
mène avec la police nationale puisque
c'est nous qui sommes les les mettre
entre guillemets des des caméras de
surveillance qui quadrillent le
territoire
le pilote supposée du scooter la semaine
dernière aux hôtes saint claude a été
interpellé hier et condamné aujourd'hui
à cinq ans de prison
il a 20 ans et il nie les faits il
possède déjà un casier judiciaire quant
aux policiers de la bac
il va mieux mais il est encore
aujourd'hui hospitalisé